you can hardly imagine like in 1988 that
you'd end up in the Rock Roll Hall of
Fame given the way a lot of people
reacted to that when it came out yeah I
would never think that we would get
there you know I'll never think that
people would ever look at us other than
you know thugs you know who's just
foul-mouthed and you know what they call
ghetto it feels great it feels like we
were right everybody else was wrong we
were right but you made this point about
how like rock n roll is not about the
instruments you play you know that it's
about an attitude I mean it's the spirit
you know I think you know the Blues has
that spirit I think jazz has that spirit
of course traditional rock and roll punk
rock and rap hip-hop you know has that
spirit of we're not going to conform to
what music say we should conform to we
are outside box we do things outside the
box we do it how we feel it and I think
music is always evolving you got
Grandmaster Flash the Furious Five Run
DMC The Beastie Boys Public Enemy and
now you guys that's you know comes up to
my counting is regular the fifth and the
hip hop back to make it into the hall
that like I is that it yeah well I mean
I believe there's some so Lord is that
belief that deserve to be in there you
know and yeah I probably have a laundry
list but to me that just speaks that you
know hip-hop needs it's on all the fame
on this level and you know it will put
in a couple rock-and-roll acts
so you're not playing right you know no
guys are not going to play so what what
had passed how's that you guys ended up
not actually ended up on stage and I
also want the reason I was going to go
yeah I mean it just it just never
happened you know it's like when you got
dr. Dre and me and ran and Yeller you
know we wanted to do it real big and now
I guess it was was the only ones that
really wanted to do it on the level that
we want to do it so it just couldn't
happen so we feel like if we couldn't
put on the best show for the people that
we possibly could and it's probably
better for us to just go enjoy the night
and have fun with it so I saw that
interview didn't the times referred you
as a brash political gangster rap that
was how he described it anyway right so
I just want to think about the word
political in there like when you guys
started out did you think of yourselves
as a political act did you over the
politics of NWA no I mean we we said
you're about to witness the strength of
Street knowledge meaning you are about
to witness you know a knowledge coming
off the streets or out the streets that
you may not have ever witnessed before
we just wanted to be real we just wanted
to be honest Street knowledge is a term
to me it means letting the streets know
what the government politics police
whatever authority figures are are doing
up to exposing them and also letting who
if the politicians are listening letting
them know what the streets think and how
things are going and hopefully there's
some understanding that could be made in
all this you became like a flashpoint in
a lot of ways was I like to experience
that and when you look back on it and
seem totally crazy to you that like you
guys were at the center of so much
controversy yeah it was weird and we
didn't think the world cared what was
going on in Compton South Central Wyatts
Long Beach we didn't we didn't think
nobody care but to speak on it and to do
music and to get artists recognition
it was it was great but also we had to
realize and grow up real fast because we
felt the powers that be
what kind of convergent on us you know
at the time and it became a freedom of
speech issue and you had people really
trying to shut down music on that level
uh you know really talking about taking
it to Congress and and doing things like
that you know you had you know people
from you know the PMRC
you know led by tip of gore and you know
you had cede the lowest Tucker and you
know countless other people coming out
the Woodworks really trying to say that
you know music was the cause of all evil
in the world and we knew that wasn't
true and so the compromise that was made
was to put the parental advisory
stickers on the records to show parents
ok these records contain subject matter
that might not be cool for your kids to
hear but I'm sort of surprised given all
the stuff that's going on the black
lives matter stuff in Ferguson and all
that's up I'm surprised there's not more
political hip-hop now doesn't seem like
it's a wise amid there's not more action
we're doing what you guys were doing
being more in the social commentary
business in some way like it was in the
late 80s early 90s
listen it's not rewarded at all it's not
rewarded on radio it's now rewarded you
know uh you know if you go political and
go hardcore with it you know you just
really kind of you know set yourself
straight into the underground you know
this was back in then about 93
gatekeepers of the airway started to say
you know that kind of political rap
we're really not gonna play that that's
not really in style and they started to
play and and and promote the the
escapism kind of rat you know sex drugs
money cars women clothes
you know clubbing just all the excess
became more popular and more exposed so
you have new hip hoppers saying how do I
get famous well it's not like Public
Enemy it's not like Boogie Down
Productions because not seeing their
stuff as much anymore you know it's more
like the new stuff that's coming on and
I'm I feel so kind of rap start taking
over and it's just kind of like it
creates its own weather because by the
10-year window
94 85 to 95 or just pure variety and
greatness right so the movie comes out
last year right Australia Compton and it
comes out at this moment when you got
Ferguson Baltimore Staten Island all
these incidents of you know police
brutality and it was like a lot of the
stuff that you guys were talking about
in 1988 1989 was suddenly like super
relevant again to a bunch of stuff that
was going on right in a lot of ways it's
a shame that the same thing we were
going through the same thing that's
still happening and and not too much has
changed with the behavior of the
authorities on you know just realizing
that that you know it's not cool to prey
on your own citizens it's just never
cool so the movie was a huge success
like if I was going to get some Academy
Award nominations and didn't write
you're proud of that movie right yeah
I'm very proud your son's in it right it
was part of the controversy around the
Oscars this year right the Oscars so
white thing does that look to you like
institutional racism do you look at the
Academy and think you know they got a
race problem I wouldn't say you know
it's institutional racism it's just the
way it's been and that's the way it is
and it has to change and but that's the
finish line you know the Oscars is the
finish line it has to change at the
starting line that's where it has to
change you know we have to give you know
more movies greenlit and better quality
movies greenlit you know
shreya compter movie was great because
of the quality we was able to put into
it you know and still the movie costs
under 30 million dollars it's a shame
you know you would you know really put
it in context you know what they were
doing
Rolling Stones movie or you know 30
million dollars would probably be the
Wardrobe it's all you need more need
more black studio executives more black
producers more black you know film
tenants here is more like the whole
whole structure of the industry a host
the whole well you know they just need
to be more inclusive to their audience
you know their audience is totally
diverse across the board and they want
to see stories about themselves you know
so the thing is you want to service your
customers with what they want and you
know and of course we believe that
another black experience in America or
in the world is definitely movie worthy
and we want to tell more stories so
people can understand who we are just
like we can understand who you know the
Oscar so white people are right
understand that pretty well yeah we're
talking about barbershop you wear the
t-shirt at the next minute right just
coming out now talk about the way which
the gang violence is happening in
Chicago is kind of a backdrop for the
movie well you know you can't really do
a fennec movie about a barbershop on the
south side of Chicago without talking
about what's happening right outside the
doors dealing with the same problems our
audience is dealing with Calvin has a
fourteen-year-old son now trying to keep
him out streets which is very Universal
to any parent trying to keep the kid on
the right track so you know one of the
things that was going on in the summer
like I said last summer when the when
trailer copy came out was the beginning
of this black lives matter movement you
know one race and the culture is being
treated you know pretty unfairly and
it's probably more than one is it's
probably a few that
are being treated pretty unfairly by the
system so that has to be addressed and I
think the fact that you even have to say
black lives matter let you know how bad
the problem is and I know a lot of
people blur the lines and say well the
black lives matter the black people of
course they do you know and they talk
about black-on-black crime but all
communities commit crime against their
own so there's white on white crime so
Mexican on Mexican crime Chinese on
Chinese Japanese on Japanese Indian on
Indian whatever everybody does that so
what we're talking about and what
they're talking about in black lives
matter is the government killing
citizens that is a whole different
texture and a whole different argument
and it's apples and oranges to me you
know when when the government is against
you who's with you in this in the
country that's the best the thing that
people who don't understand the black
lives matter movement need to understand
when you feel that the government is
against you who's going to be which Bill
Clinton was giving a speech down in
Philadelphia and had a bunch of black
lives matter protesters came in and
tried to shout him down and they're
upset they remember back in the 90s when
Hillary Clinton run for president now
route over talked about gang members as
super predators and was had used that
kind of rhetoric to to justify the
notion of a lot of the tough crime
policies that her husband and the
Congress all those people passed you
know super predator that's like the kind
of stuff people used to say about the
guys nwa right and the end the culture
he has represented on it seems crazy
that we're still having this
conversation in 2016
yeah i mean you know ii think things
haven't changed like you know like what
the movie i said you know the more
things change the more they stay the
same you know to call your own citizens
super predators
is pretty harsh and putting on this
pretty big indictment you know it's just
like the time thug or or hoodlums you
know it's just a easy brush to paint
somebody with and it's and it's really
not solving the problem is just making
it worse
because now you have you know the people
are the authorities feel like okay now
they're justified at how they treat
these so-called super predators and what
is that who is that I mean specifically
who are you talking about
cuz you know the thing back in the 80s
daryl gates in LAPD they did a war on
gangs right sure
but if I'm a black kid that's not in a
gang and I have but I look like a gang
member to this white officer then it's a
war on me so that's the problem with the
time like super predators and for some
reason the Democrats feel like they're
exempt from these protests like we're
Democrats why are you talking to us like
this go talk to the Republicans no no
everybody's a little guilty of putting
you know of a turn in a bag or you know
or passing bad legislation and everybody
should be called out on it that like so
make sense to you that that conversation
still happened like the black lives
matter wants to prosecute that case that
may seems like still totally legit of
course yeah of course because she might
be the President of the United States
you know and if she becomes the
President of the United States we need
to know what she's thinking how does she
think how's she gonna handle how's she
gonna fix this you know she helped
create it in a way how are you gonna fix
it he's got a point of view about Donald
Trump uh well you know Donald Trump is
what Americans love Donald Trump is what
Americans aspire to be rich powerful do
what you want to do say what you want to
say be how you want to be that's kind of
been like the American dream so he looks
like a boss to everybody and
Americans LaHood I have a boss so you
know that's his appeal to me you know do
I think he's going to do anything to
help poor people or people that
struggling no because you know he's rich
white guy how does he how can he relate
you know he's always been rich and you
know being rich don't make you bad ain't
saying that but I'm just saying how can
he relate right how can he relate to the
small guy for a lot of people like when
Trump even before he ran for president
four years ago when he was like one of
the leaders of the birther movement and
was loudly going around saying that
President Obama was not legitimate
president and that he was born in Kenya
for a lot of people that's like that
man's a racist you feel like that I
still I mean I'm still mad he took down
the USFL I think that was a cool league
right stressing for the summer but
anyway yeah yeah uh nah man you know
it's like he sounded crazy to meet in
you know I could see raising the
question but once you get to answer him
and move on you know to still harp on it
and to lie that you're sending
investigators and all this stuff to me
was was just a guy who couldn't who
couldn't say that he was wrong right and
what do you think about you got any
thoughts about Bernie Sanders you
feeling the Bern at all uh guy talked
about the 1% I mean you know that for
politically it's like he's been in there
30 years and you know what have you done
what have you done you've been there
you've been up in there so what are you
gonna do different from a whole you know
from outside Congress now you and you
know whisk was what's going to happen
different where you been I you know so
all of them to me got got work to do to
get my vote what are they what's what
should they be talking about right I
mean again is a doesn't mean talking
about a lot of the stuff that black
lives matter cares about most talking
about like trying to fix the problems in
big cities dealing with police issues
deal with mass incarceration all that
kind of stuff is that the kind of stuff
that matters that that's got to have a
bigger place in the campaign in your oh
it's not just saying it or not just
mentioned what needs to be done
it's like I need to see how what's the
plan I need to believe in your plan if I
don't see it or believe it it's just
politician lip service to me because I
can sit up there and stand up there and
say we need more jobs we need the better
healthcare if you were going to be a
politician you do that pretty well we
need more damage I need to I need to you
know give my point together
yeah have a good you got to have a good
point it is that yeah I figure things
are going to keep Donald [ __ ]
it's almost the end of the Obama
administration you feel like he's been a
success if you like yeah I feel like
he's been a great great president um you
know because you know he's dealing with
one thing dealing with the recession and
the collapse and all that and you know
holding the country together really um
you know not in that way but you know
Congress haven't worked with him to be
able to do some of these great things
you know and I was real disappointed in
the Blue Dog Democrats and I was real
disappointed in the Congressional Black
Caucus where you been all these eight
years you know I was like were you at
why you not help helping the men achieve
the things that he'd need he was trying
to get done and I just felt like this
Congress treated him like a black head
who goes to a hallway school but they
don't play one it was play with